>>> A MAJOR ESCALATION IN
UKRAINE WITH RUSSIA'S WAR.
THE WHITE HOUSE ANNOUNCING NEW
SANCTIONS, AND RUSSIA MAKING IT
OFFICIAL THAT HE IS HAVING A
SIGNING CEREMONY THAT PRESIDENT
PUTIN SAYS THOSE TERRITORIES ARE
NOW PART OF RUSSIA, AND IN HIS
WORDS, FOREVER.
>> Translator: I WANT THE KYIV
AND THE MASTERS IN THE WEST TO
HEAR ME AND REMEMBER THAT THOSE
PEOPLE WHOLEY IN THESE FOUR
REGIONS ARE BECOMING OUR
CITIZENS FOREVER.
>> OUR CHIEF WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENT CAITLYN COLLINS IS
STANDING OUTSIDE OF THE WHITE
HOUSE, AND NIC, WHAT HAPPENED
TODAY AND WHAT ARE THE
IMPLICATIONS FOR THE WAR?
>> WHAT HAPPENED TODAY IS WHAT
EVERYONE HAS BEEN EXPECTING
WHICH IS RUSSIA FORMALLY
DECLARING WITH A HUGE DEGREE OF
FALSITY IN THE STATEMENT THAT
WHERE I AM STANDING IN UKRAINE
IS EFFECTIVELY RUSH SHARKS AND
THE PROBLEM THEY HAVE IS THAT
THE FOUR AREAS THEY SAY THAT ARE
NOW RUSSIA, THEY ARE NOT
MILITARILY CONTROLLING, AND ALL
OF THEM PARTICULARLY HERE IN
DONETSK AND WHAT PUTIN HAS SAID
IN A REVISIONIST WAY THAT RUSSIA
AND THE SOVIET UNION HAVE BEEN
VICTIMIZED BY THE WEST AND
FORCED INTO A POSITION TO
PROTECT THE WIDER RUSSIAN SLAVIC
PEOPLE, AND THAT IS NONSENSE
WHEN YOU THINK OF THE DAMAGE
THEY HAVE DONE TO THE PEOPLE
THEY CLAIM TO PROTECT AND THE
DAMAGE THEY HAVE DONE SINCE
FEBRUARY, BUT IT IS SHOCKED AND
BEWILDERED FACES IN KREMLIN HALL
SHARING THE VIEW OF THE REALITY
OF THE WORLD THAT VLADIMIR PUTIN
WAS TRYING TO EXTOL.
WHAT DOES IT MEAN ON THE GROUND
HERE?
WELL, VLADIMIR PUTIN DID NOT
DIRECTLY THREATEN TO USE THE
NUCLEAR WEAPONS TO PROTECT THE
TERRITORY WHICH OFFICIALS HAVE
DONE IN THE PAST, BUT HE HINTED
AT THE POSSIBILITY, BUT IT IS
NOT SOMETHING THAT HE
SPECIFICALLY SAID.
SO WE ARE NOW STILL FACING A
SITUATION WHERE THE RUSSIAN
TROOPS ARE LOSING, AND NOT
GETTING ENOUGH PEOPLE TO THE
FRONT TO CHANGE THE DYNAMIC
HERE, AND WE ARE SEEING THAT
EVEN WHEN HE WAS SPEAKING THE
UKRAINIAN FORCES WERE MOVING
FORCES TOWARDS A RAILWAY TOWN
THAT IS ENCIRCUMSTANCE BLD I THE
UKRAINIAN FORCES WITH THOUSANDS
OF IMPORTANT WELL-EQUIPPED
RUSSIAN TROOPS CUT OFF AND
STRANDED THERE, AND THAT COULD
CAUSE ANOTHER POTENTIAL DOMINO
EFFECT NEAR WHERE I AM STANDING
MORE RUSSIAN TERRITORIAL LOSSES,
AND WE HAVE SEEN UKRAINE ON THE
FRONT FORWARD DISMISSING THIS
ANNEXATION OF NO CONSEQUENCE AND
ASKING TO QUICKLY JOIN NATO AS
POSSIBLE, AND  TND THEY HAVE WA
THAT, BUT IT IS INJECTING A MORE
TERRITORIAL TENSION HERE.
AND THEY SAY THERE ARE MORE
CARDS TO PLAY, BUT IT HAS NOT
CHANGED HERE ON THE GROUND.
>> AND NOW THE KAITLAN COLLINS
ON THE GROUND AT THE WHITE
HOUSE, AND NOW LOOKING AT THE
STRANGE OF THE STRATEGIC OF THE
SCREEN WE ARE LOOKING AT THE
MAP, AND WHAT DOES IT MEAN TO
CHANGE FOR THE WHITE HOUSE MOU?
>> IT IS THE WHITE HOUSE NOT
ONLY CONDEMNING IT, BUT IF YOU
ARE LISTENING TO THE SPEECH FROM
PUTIN TODAY, HE IS FRAMING IT AS
THE EXISTENTIAL CRISIS OF THE
WEST AND RUSRUSSIA, AND HE IS
VIEWING THE CONDEMNING OF THE
MOVE THAT THE WHITE HOUSE SAYS
THEY KNEW IT WAS COMING OF THE
FOUR TERRITORIES AND IT IS
BRAZEN, AND VIOLATION OF
INTERNATIONAL LAW, AND TRAMPLES
ON THE UNITED NATIONS CHARTER
AND THAT RUSSIA IS SHOWING
CONTEMPT OF PEACEFUL NATIONS
EVERYWHERE BY DOING THIS, AND
TAKING ACTIONS OF IMPOSING
SANCTIONS, JOHN, AND FURTHER
TRYING TO CRIPPLE RUSSIA'S
DEFENSE AND TECHNICAL SECTOR BY
GOING AFTER ANY COMPANIES THAT
PROVIDE TECHNICAL OR FINANCIAL
SUPPORT TO RUSSIA, AND THEY WILL
IMPOSE SANCTIONS IS, AND PUT IN
PLACE THESE EXPORT CONTROLS
WHICH IS THE STEP THEY ARE GOING
TO DO, AND TARGETING THE TOP
RUSSIAN OFFICIAL, BUT THE
QUESTIONS ARE THE BIGGER ONES OF
UKRAINE SAYING THEY WILL SUBMIT
THE APPLICATION TO JOIN NATO,
AND THEY WANT IT TO BE AN
EXPEDITED PROCESS.
WHAT IS THE WHITE HOUSE'S
RESPONSE TO THAT, AND PRESIDENT
BIDEN SAID HE WILL BE SPEAKING
ON THIS LATER TODAY ABOUT THE
MOVE TO RUSSIA, AND IN ADDITION
TO THE STATEMENT THAT HE PUT
OUT, AND THE TREASURY AND THE
COMMERCE DEPARTMENTS ON THE
ATTEMPT TO PUNISH IT, BUT IT IS
RAISING A BIGGER QUESTION OF HOW
THIS CONFLICT COULD POTENTIALLY
END ESPECIALLY WITH THE SPEECH
FROM PRESIDENT PUTIN TODAY.
AFTER THE KREMLIN HELD
CELEBRATION CEREMONIES,
VOLODYMYR ZELENSKYY MADE HIS
NEXT MOVE.
THE UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT
ANNOUNCED HIS COUNTRY IS FAST
TRACKING MAY NATO MEMBERSHIP
APPLICATIONS, AND ACCELERATING
THE PROCEDURE THAT HE CALLED
MOSCOW'S, QUOTE, ATTEMPTED
ANNEXATION.
AND HE ACCUSE THE RUSSIAN
LEADER OF WANTING TO READ RIGHT
HISTORY AND REDRAW BORDERS WITH
MURDERS, TORTURE, BLACKMAILING
LIES.
CNN'S MATTHEW CHANCE JOINS ME
LIVE FROM NEW YORK.
MATTHEW, PUTIN FORMALIZING
THESE REGIONS AS RUSSIAN
TERRITORY HAS FAR-REACHING
CONSEQUENCES.
CAN YOU TAKE US THROUGH WHAT HE
SAYS IT MEANS?
WHILE UKRAINE IS TRYING TO
RECLAIM LOST GROUND.
>> IT'S A BIG ESCALATION OF THE
CONFLICT IN THE SENSE THAT
RUSSIA HAS INCORPORATED THESE
FOUR REGIONS, FORMALLY.
THAT'S SUBJECT TO THE RUBBER
STANCE APPROVAL OF THE RUSSIAN
PARLIAMENT INTO THE RUSSIAN
FEDERATION.
IT'S A POWERFUL MESSAGE THAT
PUTIN IS SENDING TO HIS
DOMESTIC AUDIENCE.
IT REINTEGRATES THE KREMLIN
PROPAGANDA THAT THE REGIONS
WANTED TO JOIN RUSSIA.
IT'S ALSO A STRONG MESSAGE TO
THE INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY AS
WELL.
THAT DESPITE THE FUNDAMENTAL
OPPOSITION THAT'S BEEN
EXPRESSED TO HIM AND RUSSIA
DOING THIS, HE'LL DO IT ANYWAY
REGARDLESS OF THE CONSEQUENCES.
MORE THAN THAT HE IS GOING TO
HE SAID THIS, HE'S GOING TO
DEFEND THESE TERRITORIES WITH
EVERYTHING RUSSIA HAS IF
NECESSARY.
HE'S OPEN TO PEACE TALKS, HE
SAID, WITH UKRAINE.
THE FUTURE OF THESE TERRITORIES
WILL NOT BE ON THE TABLE.
SO THIS IS VLADIMIR PUTIN DOING
WHAT HE ALWAYS DOES.
WHICH IS WHEN HE'S BACKED INTO
A CORNER HE DOUBLES DOWN, HE
DOESN'T BACK DOWN, HE DOUBLES
THEM.
AND THAT'S WHAT HE'S DOING NOW.
IT LEADS US INTO A VERY
DANGEROUS AND UNPREDICTABLE
AREA IN WHICH WE'VE GOT RUSSIA
SAYING THIS IS NOW RUSSIAN
TERRITORY AND IF YOU ATTACK IT
WILL POTENTIALLY USE OUR
NUCLEAR DETERRENT TO COMBAT
THAT.
WHILE THERE'S A MASSIVE
OFFENSIVE GOING ON BY THE
UKRAINIANS MAKING TERRITORIAL
ADVANCES IN THAT PART OF
UKRAINE.
AGAIN, A VERY DANGEROUS
SITUATION.
>> YEAH, EXACTLY, ANTHONY
BLINKEN WAS WORRIED ABOUT
WHETHER IT WAS GOING TO BE
ANNEXED AND WHAT THAT WOULD
MEAN IF PUTIN SEES IT AS
RUSSIAN TERRITORY.
WHAT DID IT TAKE LISTENING TO
LISTENING TO THE NATO SECRETARY
GENERAL.
HE SAID THE TERRITORY IS STILL
CONSIDERED UKRAINIAN, LISTEN.
>> THIS LAND GRAB IS ILLEGAL
AND ILLEGITIMATE.
NATO ALLIES DO NOT AND WILL NOT
RECOGNIZE ANY OF THIS TERRITORY
AS PART OF RUSSIA.
WE CALL ON ALL STATES TO REJECT
RUSSIA'S BLATANT ATTEMPTS AT
TERRITORIAL CONQUEST.
THESE LANDS ARE UKRAINE.
>> ALL RIGHT, WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN TO MOSCOW, MATTHEW?
WHAT DO THESE WORDS MEAN FOR
MOSCOW?
>> FRANKLY I DON'T THINK IT'LL
HAVE MUCH IMPACT ON MOSCOW.
THE FACT THAT THE SECRETARY
GENERAL OF NATO DOESN'T
ACKNOWLEDGE THIS.
MORE IMPORTANTLY, THE
UKRAINIANS THEMSELVES HAVE
OBVIOUSLY CATEGORICALLY
REJECTED THE ANNEXATION.
AND THEY SAID THAT THEY ARE
GOING TO ACCELERATE THEIR
APPLICATION TO JOIN THE NATO,
THE WESTERN MILITARY ALLIANCE,
NATO.
AND SO I THINK WHAT WILL BE
INTERESTING HERE IS WHAT JENS
STOLTENBERG, THE SECRETARY
GENERAL OF NATO HAS TO SAY
ABOUT THAT.
OBVIOUSLY IT'S PRETTY UNLIKELY
AT THIS POINT, I WOULD SAY,
THAT NATO WOULD EMBRACE UKRAINE
AS IT'S IN FULL BLOWN
COMPETITION WITH A NUCLEAR ON
RUSSIA.
BUT WHO KNOWS?
THIS CONFLICT IS ESCALATING AT
A DRAMATIC, UNPREDICTABLE AND
FRIGHTENING PACE.
>> YEAH, AND IT'S SUCH A GOOD
POINT.
I WAS REFLECTING ON WHAT
VLADIMIR PUTIN SAID A WEEK AGO.
HE SAID, I'M NOT LAUGHING WHEN
HE WAS TALKING ABOUT NUCLEAR
WEAPONS OR ESCALATION.
WE ARE SEEING IMAGES COMING
THROUGH FROM RUSSIA RIGHT NOW,
WE SAW CELEBRATION ON THE GO,
VLADIMIR PUTIN IS IN ENGAGING
WITH AN AUDIENCE AND DECLARING
VICTORY.
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT THIS
BEING IN A ESCALATION.
AGAIN, ANY USE OF NUCLEAR
WEAPONS, ANY NUCLEAR RISK WILL
HAVE DIRE CONSEQUENCES FOR ALL
SIDES.
>> YES, IT WOULD.
AND IT WOULD NECESSARILY MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IN TERMS OF MILITARY
GAINS EITHER.
IT'S VLADIMIR PUTIN, IF HE
KILLS 1 MILLION PEOPLE IT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT UKRAINE FALLS
UNDER HIS WAY.
LOOK, THESE IMAGES ARE REALLY
STRIKING THAT WE'RE SEEING NOW.
THIS IS A HIGHLY CHOREOGRAPHED
BIT OF NATIONALISTIC FERVOR IN
THE CENTER OF THE RUSSIAN
CAPITAL.
PEOPLE ARE ATTENDING THIS
CONCERT AS RUSSIA PROCLAIMS THE
ANNEXATION OF THESE FOUR
REGIONS OF UKRAINE.
YOU CAN HEAR THEM CHANTING,
RUSSIA, RUSSIA.
AND THEY'VE BEEN TOLD TO DO
THAT.
I DON'T THINK THE MOOD ACROSS
THE COUNTRY, THIS IS A
REFLECTION OF THAT,
NECESSARILY.
IN THE PAST COUPLE OF WEEKS, OR
THE PAST COUPLE OF DAYS WE'VE
SEEN HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE TRYING TO MAKE THEIR WAY
TO THE EXITS OF RUSSIA TO
ESCAPE THE MILITARY DRAFT.
THE REALITY OF THE SPECIAL
MILITARY OPERATION IN UKRAINE,
WHICH HAS BEEN COSTLY IN TERMS
OF HUMAN LIFE ON THE RUSSIAN
AND UKRAINIAN SIDE HAS REALLY
HIT HOME WITH RUSSIANS AND THAT
IMPACT WILL CONTINUE TO SOUR
ATTITUDES TOWARDS IT.